question au combat bonsoir souvent
reconnaissez olivier de kersauson caisse
au tac ada joey starr clotilde courau le
petit guillaume canet qui vient de faire
un film très brillant bas par rapport à
moi était petit et françois berléand qui
joue non seulement dans ce film et dans
l'enfant do voilà alors vous êtes
journaliste romancier et ce soir vous
êtes essayiste ou mieux polémiste
puisque vous publié aux éditions du
rocher
un livre qui s'appelle enfants sans foi
ni loi et sur le bandeau il ya écrit
ascenseur pour les fachos
[Musique]
alors christian combas votre thèse c'est
que 68 à tuer le père un tué le curé le
flic le moniteur l'entraîneur c'est la
fin de l'autorité est depuis trente ans
on va vers l'anarchie anarchie qui
suscite comme tout les anarchies dites
vous un désir d'ordre voire de dictature
voilà c'est pas tout à fait ma thèse
c'est la moitié de ma thèse ouais ma
thèse c'est effectivement qu'il ya eu
qu'on a tué le père mais ça tout le
monde l'a eu cette thèse là en revanche
le complément que j'essaie d'apporter
c'est que les soixante huitards se sont
pas contentés de se heurter aux pères et
d'essayer de le tuer est de mise y sont
parvenus c'est à dire qu'ils ont vacciné
leurs propres enfants contre l'autorité
c'est ça le problème est là il est
absolument légitime de s'opposer à une
autorité qu'on a rencontrés mais ce qui
est dégueulasse c'est de dire à son fils
de 5 ans c'est d'inciter son fils de 5
ans à se moquer de tous les pouvoirs par
définition parce que on sait pas tout le
monde sent qu'à fils de 5 ans a besoin
de se heurter à quelque chose d'avoir
une espèce de barrières même s'ils
veulent a sauté il faut qu'il faut
qu'ils les destinées devant lui mais
pour voir transgresser la règle alors
les soixante huitards dont nous avons
tous plus ou moins fait partie parce que
vous avez oui nous avons tous plus ou
moins été levée par des familles trop
rigide bon ont eu le bonheur de se
heurter à quelqu'un et donc de sauter la
barrière
les enfants d'aujourd'hui de la
rencontre pour ainsi dire jamais et
quand il l'a rencontrée c'est un peu ça
le nom de notre problème en ce moment
c'est qu'il raconte très très tard il
rencontre dans la rue c'est le flic
ils ont déjà 14 ans un bâtard alors vous
dis qu'effectivement la jeunesse invente
par la violence l'autorité qu'elle n'a
jamais subi hélas toutes les toutes les
bandes organisées sont vraiment organisé
autour de la violence et de
l'intimidation enfin tout le monde a
bien vu ça à la fois dans les films je
pense que je vais star ne peut pas jouer
il peut pas nier quand même il peut pas
nier que dans la bande il ya une
hiérarchie
si le niger est observé j'ai observé
j'ai entendu dire que dans les bandes
beaucoup de bandes
tout le monde le sait même d'aller chez
les scouts il ya une hiérarchie dans la
bande c'est à dire qu' il ya des images
ou des scouts et puis je suis d'accord
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que dès
qu'il ya un groupe soudé qui est un
groupe qui ne subit pas d'autorité venu
d'en haut
en général les aptitudes se manifestent
assez rapidement et ses aptitudes donne
lieu à des vocations des vocations de
chefs comme ça que ça se passe on essaie
d'avancer comme un seul homme mais alors
vous parlez d'apparition dans les pays
où les adultes ont perdu leurs canines
d'une génération d'enfants loup écoutez
or on en revient à votre à ce que vous
disiez précédemment à propos du désir
d'ordre c'est ça enfin on n'a pas vu
réellement la meute se former est
réellement mais on sent tout de même un
désir d'ordre naître et ce désir d'or
par exemple il prend la forme
hélas de certaines de certain
soulagement que l'on observe y compris
la télévision certains jeunes vont chez
l'imam du coin parce que c'est le seul
endroit où ils ont une espèce de règles
quotidienne ils sont contents qu'on leur
dise barrette tu vaux mieux que ça
quelqu'un leur dis enfin tu vaux mieux
que ça et je trouve ça dommage que
l'autorité laïque ne soit pas là pour
leur dire à cinq ans ou à 7 ans à red
bull de bondir partout arrête d'emmerder
le monde tu vaux mieux que ça
normalement c'est l'âge où on le dit ça
vous pensez quoi de ce vivier ques et
passait pas et n'est pas ce que dit le
barbu qui à ma gauche on trouve que
il faut sans interdit il n'y a pas de ya
pas de vraie liberté donc ya pas de
jouissance de la liberté je pense que et
même si les interdits de son fait pour
elle saute et il faut qu'ils existent
dalhousie dans toutes les sociétés du
monde dans toutes les sociétés
primitives l'interdît on a fait ce qu'on
veut mais il existe quelqu'un sinon
c'est le l'adolescence et un permanence
un coup de poing dans le vide mais on se
fait mal à taper dans le vide
en fait on se fabrique à taper sur
quelque chose de dur donc la notion qui
a soutenu le professeur ce qui ont
dépassé de barbus un professeur
maintenant je pense que ce qu'il est
écrit n'est pas inepte
c'est une nécessité ça fait aussi partie
de la construction d'un individu lc
bonheur parce qu'on ne consomme se
construit pas sans se heurter
si on se remet jamais aussi sont aussi
sur offers très tard à ce moment là ça
devient une blessure non pas un coût
mais c'est l'impression qu'a dans 68 où
il y avait donc soi-disant de l'odeur de
l'autorité il y avait des mecs qui
s'engagent et en un truc complètement
con donc ça n'empêchait rien fait moi
j'ai jamais été contraint de ma vie ça
m'a pas empêché de faim n'est pas devenu
pour autant mais toi tu est élevé à la
dure quand même nom mais je dois réduire
mais jamais jamais dans l'autorité
jamais jamais dans l' autorité allait
nettoyer le haras tous les matins et
tous les écuries et ou non mais c'est
vrai qu'il a été élevé à la dure n'a pas
été bon non non non non je me laisse
c'est avait jambes
françois blanchet plus on est contraint
plus on a envie d'exploser quoi donc si
justement ça c'est un peu ma thèse c'est
que il vaut mieux ça te reposer quelque
chose pour que c'est pour se construire
je vais exploser c'est devenir très con
c'est à dire quand je dis explosé c'est
que plus on va être contraint à faire
quelque chose à rien pouvoir faire
à un moment à un moment et ben on se
retrouve
à 25 piges et puis on a envie de faire
des conneries parce qu'on a été empêché
d'en faire alors que si on est élevé
d'une manière ou non ce qui est bien ce
qui pas bien eh ben on va se prendre
trois cadres claques dans la gueule et
puis après on va prendre et on va
prendre le chemin comme comme on a envie
de le prendre alors il ya deux
déclencheur dans l'écriture de ce livre
christian conte base est d'abord une
thèse d'une dénommée georgette moutons
qui a écrit jeunesse et génèse du
nazisme et qui explique très bien dans
cette thèse dont vous parlez dans votre
bouquin que finalement en allemagne
contrairement à ce qu'on a cru c'est pas
une autorité supérieure qui a amené le
nazisme mais c'est le libertarisme du
début du 20e siècle
c'est pas les quinquagénaires en
entretien oui c'est ça c'est plutôt les
jeunes gens en gros en 1900 en allemagne
les proportions gardées il y avait déjà
des rêveurs des rêveurs comme les rave
partys
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des grands
rassemblements les jeunes gens
refusaient l'autorité des parents
disaient la famille et oppressif par
nature le poly professeur vous
apprennent des choses périmés et donc
qu'ils sont rassemblés pour faire la
fête ensemble puis la fête a mal tourné
parce qu'il ya une autre jeunesse qui
est arrivé juste après elle avait
beaucoup moins le sens de l'humour
et puis ça a coïncidé avec la guerre de
14 il a des fêtes puis l'a carrément les
choses ont tourné à l'aigre le sang
connaît la suite
alors ça c'est le premier déclencheur le
deuxième c'est l' aventure de ce médecin
accoucheur dont vous parlez qui a mis un
garçon que vous appelez steve au monde
c'est lui qui a accouché sa mère donc et
un jour steve agressent le médecin
accoucheur et lui dit si tu vas aux
flics je te crève
alors ça c'est évidemment c'est une
espèce de fable qui a le mérite d'être
vrai hélas c'est ce type avait eu il a
rencontré la mère de ce garçon la mère
lui a rappelé vous savez que vous avez
accouché mais trois gars aux vins est
donc comme il a vu ce type avec un
couteau à la main dans le train trois
jours après ici dix grands dieux ce type
que j'ai mis au monde me tend un couteau
ouais c'est une fable sociale de
vertigineuses et il me pose la question
qu'est ce que nous avons fait pour que
les enfants que nous avons mis au monde
menace de nous tuer à tous les enfants
évidemment c'est une caricature puisque
c'est une fable mais c'est une fable
vrai malheureusement si ça se produit
pas souvent ça se produit trop souvent
alors le pire de tous cas l'air de le
plus le choquer ce médecin accoucheur
c'est quand il va chez les flics et que
les flics lui dit
s'il vous retrouve ils vont vous pourrir
la vie ça c'est malheureusement aussi
les gens nous si ça se passe comme ça jo
et lorsque et puisque nous sommes
justement ce qui m'emmerde un peu dans
cette histoire de dérives de la société
actuelle c'est que l'intimidation de
proximité quoi qu'on dise est en train
de progresser
c'est à dire que l'intimidation
proximité ça veut dire si tu continues
tu auras mais quatre copains sur le dos
pendant huit mois
ça c'est ennuyeux sache que neige oui
mais justement 7,7 ce mode de
comportement d'individus d'un individu à
un autre qui passe par le groupe qui
passe par l'intimidation c'est l'essence
même du fascisme de 1925 en allemagne
c'est tout ce sont les bandes armées qui
vient de faire le pied de grue sous chez
vous et qui vous pourrissent la vie puis
celle de votre fille puis celle de votre
fils on a vu quelques reportages
peut-être trop parce que notre avis la
télévision atn a toujours tendance à
accentuer le nombre de ce cas mais même
si ces trois cas c'est déjà trois cadres
trop de femmes de flics qui sont
martyrisés au point de devoir déménager
c'est un peu ennuyeux mine de rien quand
on ment aux enfants de 10 ans dans la
course est encore plus ennuyeux parce
que s'il ya une innocence c'est bien
celle-là donc cette dérive là il faut
l'arrêter met donc le médecin pendant
l'été il faut que la mode change il faut
que la mode change il faut que par
exemple dans un téléfilm quand on
présente les citations de ce genre le
metteur en scène soit moins indulgent
avec sa caméra qu'il ne l'a été durant
les dix dernières années on a trop vu
d'intimidation ça c'est la non mais là
ça s'apparente à de la censure conrad
riz qui présente à prêter en ce qu'ils
présentent avec des excuses d'ailleurs
avec des excuses vraiment des vraies
excuses birkin août qui nous émeut avec
le cas d'un jeune homme qui va en
intimider d'autres en réunissant quatre
copains c'est un metteur en scène qui
joue avec le feu et en ce moment comme
ça brûle
je suis désolé je désigne l'extincteur
et amont d'un physique beaucoup de gens
qui nous écoutent mais c'est par
l'autorité que voulait faire les choses
les autorités morales déjà parce qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'être nicolas sarkozy et
d'envoyer un bataillon l'autorité morale
ça veut dire cette gentillesse que vous
me fait cette gentillesse que vous
faites de me laisser m'exprimer ce soir
prouve que l'autorité morale parce que
je n'ai pas tarder et je n'ai pas de
bataille on est parfois suffisante pour
inciter les gens à corriger leur vie
quotidienne liberté d'expression il est
faux aussi pour le metteur en scène
parce que
mettre en scène mes économies en scène
quand on met en scène on met en scène
aussi la vie ce qui se passe
vous avez ça peut aussi d'un autre côté
montrer ce qui se passe était de faire
changer les choses depuis l'aube c'est
une objection que j'admets mais ma thèse
celle que je défends ce moment j'ai
rarement vu illustré dans un téléfilm
durant les dix dernières années ce que
j'aimerais c'est que le discours soit il
m'a lancé voilà moi qui a été éduqué
sans autorité j'ai l'impression que au
moins mes parents m'ont permis de
décider moi-même de ce qui était bien ce
qui était mal donc je n'ai pas eu besoin
d'autorité ni de figure autoritaire à la
maison qui me mettait des coups dans la
gueule pour me faire comprendre que ça
c'était pas bien écouté je les fais une
seule avec mon propre sens mais mes
propres valeurs que zamora bin oui ça
existe mais perdant aline et ça existe
pas la morale cézanne est toujours à
trois ou quatre ans du fait que le petit
garçon ou la petite fille a essayé de
prendre quelque chose on lui a dit non
non et une fois qu'il a entendu non 18
fois il commence à comprendre s'il ya un
interdit
l'interdît après il le juge il peut très
bien le transgresser mais l'interdît a
été manifestée ce que je reproche à la
société actuelle à cause des soixante
huitards qui ont quand même terriblement
théorisé si vous voulez cette affaire de
interdite
ils ont théorisé ce qu'ils ont fait des
théories nous ont dit voilà a fait gaffe
tu te rends compte comment tu dis à ton
fils non pour réfléchir ça peut être
baptisé à force de ne pas vouloir trop
baptisé le boss c'est lui qui traumatise
tout le monde il suffit d'avoir pris un
tgv 150 personnes peuvent être martyrisé
pendant trois heures de voyage par un
gamin de 50
on l'a tous vu donc je parle je dirais
que c'était généralement c'est un dingue
c'est dangereux mais moi je trouve enfin
il est en forme et dis moi ce que t'en
penses de la merde
non mais je suis loin de la merde
franchement franchement là sur les
derniers propos de la mère franchement
beaucoup du tgv qu'est ce que ça a
choqué tout le monde l'observé
tout le monde a observé que des enfants
de 5 ans pour martyriser un tgv mais
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps
en faisant enfin parce que déjà ils ont
non pas dans l'entrejeu vous en iran qui
martyrise un tgv
ah oui ça arrive là je suis désolé vous
voulez envoyer un email à notre ami pour
lui je pouvais connaître ses deux mains
je m'écoutais essayait de manifester
si vous avez un témoignage à apporter
sur un enfant de 5 ans qui a martyrisé
un tgv je suggère qu'on vous envoie le
témoignage que je pense que le sondage
est vite fait cinq ans c'est un peu
jeune fait un an que je veux dire ce qui
est un peu ennuyeux c'est que la mère
dit rarement et couverts est ferme l'a
rarement et quand elle le dit c'est ça
qui est un peu plus de tolérance clark c
est pire qu il est assez fréquent que
les voisins dire mesdames quoi donc il
ya une espèce de mode si vous voulez de
juguler une autorité dès qu'elle se
manifeste et cette mode là elle va finir
par devenir criminels dans dix ans et
c'est ça que vous avez des enfants
j'ai treize enfants mais j'en ai
beaucoup oui non mais c'est pas sympa je
suis un usager de l'enfance où je suis
bien que vous dire dans l'autobus si les
enfants marchent sur les pieds je suis
un usager de la faune sont difficiles à
gino et oui je viens à envisager de
tenues sains du gène et de l'enfance je
les vois je vous demande ça alors que je
vais pas vous de voir comment la vivez
si vous aviez des ententes être ça vous
aurez alors s'il devra évidemment le ce
problème et là je peux vous raconter
aussi une autre chose j'ai vu une barbe
un peu de de père fouettard et
d'ordinateurs effet que parfois quand
les enfants les plus jeunes et l'elysée
élevé dans la permissivité la plus
totale se heurte à moi ouais dans une
famille oui je m'y attends jean-michel
terminé le gamin surpris que quelqu'un
lui dise terminé revient vers moi d'un
indien mais tu es le seul adulte qui
mais résistait depuis trois semaines et
salue roi s'amuse et ça lui plaît c'est
tout et savage areces évidemment pas du
fascisme c'est simplement une résistance
minime doit pas avoir les mêmes
bon là c'est à dire ce que vous dites
pour résumer
mais pour résumer la situation ce que
vous dites c'est que l'autoritarisme
peut nous éviter le totalitarisme
ce que je vois c'est que la fermeté pas
l'autoritarisme la fermeté la fermeté ça
veut pas dire imposer quelque chose ça
veut dire résister à quelque chose un
exemple j'ai un ami qui a une enfant
très développée intellectuellement de
trois ans et demi à nouveau en train de
se servir de l'ordinateur elle lui dit
je veux que tu arrêtes l'ordinateur donc
laffly 10 à opera trois ans et demi et
le père au lieu des réponses c'est moi
qui décide tu vas t'asseoir là bas tu
attends le père lui dit pas tout de
suite
il lui dit oui je vais tomber lire en
quelque sorte at war enfant de 3 ans est
normal attendait oui vous avez raison
vous avez raison mais avoue j'ai des
enfants je leur dis de la même chose que
moi j'ai dit ça te fait clotilde mallard
net judith le pire crise et j'ai un truc
à expliquer ton père terminé je n'avais
pas le temps de discuter
alors la gamine a fait ça si la coupe
bout d'un quart d'heure et des revenus
s'est frotté avoir dix diables qui tue
et voilà c'est tout pas si jo et aurait
aimé l'avoir comme papa j'en ai eu un
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
sauf que sauf que le mien il avait moins
de vocabulaire gestuel
mais j'en avais un comme ça sérieux il
avait une barbe aussi un ouais il a tu
l'as toujours d'aller à tous les
attributs de l'autorité alors c'est sûr
qu'en base pour vous les responsables
sont ceux que vous appelez les imbéciles
historique 1 c'est les soixante huitards
en gros les libertaires qui sont devenu
marchand ce que la presse appelle les
bourgeois bohème vous dites ceux qui
défilent contre l'extrême droite et qui
achètent à leur enfant de 13 ans des
jeux où l'on torture les adversaires moi
ça me gêne déjà et je pense qu'une
poignée de gens qui nous écoutent qui
seront gênés par le fait qu'il existe
désormais des jeux ou sur la couverture
je suis pas la marque mais c'est de
l'une des plus célèbres sur la
couverture il ya marqué torturé vos
ennemis c'est le slogan du jeu alors là
quand même réfléchissons un instant il
ya un léger problème
ouais si c'était marqué sur la
couverture d'un livre on aurait tout le
monde sur jade
c'est à ce que vous remettez en cause là
c'est pas le manque d'autorité le
laxisme c'est ce que vous remettez en
question là c'est là ouais c'est le
mercantilisme a d'abord dit non mais pas
pour parlons des jeux vidéo parce que
c'est un thème que j'ai les mêmes au
salon wii donc c'est le mercantilisme
c'est un autre problème
non puisqu'il s'est toujours unis c'est
une dérive qui représente 5 % par
exemple de jeux vidéo il ya en france 5%
des jeux de vidéos qui sont carrément
dégueulasse il faut le dire il faut les
montrer il y en a 3 3 ou 4 titres qui
sont vendus lancement alors heureusement
c'est ce qui marche le mieux parce que
les gens sentent bien qu'ils aient
interdit qui est vraiment transgresser
quand j'en tire deux dans la tête des
gens à bout portant quand on fait le
sniper d'un toit d'immeubles avec tout
ça très scénarisé on sent bien que c'est
un jeu qui dépasse très largement le
canada ge dans les couloirs donc vous
êtes pour l'interdiction de ce type de
jeux neufs simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que les parents doivent
savoir ce qu'il ya dans la boîte
ils ne savent pas ils savent pas non
plus que par exemple il suffit de
l'installer jeu en anglais pour que le
sang commence à couler ils savent pas
que les gosses s'échange à l'école des
petits disques est grosse comme ça qui
permet de dénaturer le jeu de manière à
le rendre plus sanglant les piétons vous
demande grâce avant que vous les écrase
y est ça ils le savent pas bien aux
moules d'histoire voilà c'est tout mme
olivier si j'ai bien compris le livre de
cet excellent barbu on progresse c'est
que à un moment donné
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas se
proposait d'une certaine façon de ne pas
laisser tout faire tout le temps c'est
tout parce que le plus beau cadeau qu'on
puisse faire aux gens moi moi je moi je
suis ravi de l'éducation peut-être un
peu usé mais j'ai ensuite mes parents ce
que mon aprilia être dur est l solide
apparaître après s'être dégonflé à être
guerrier tout ça et je pense que ça
s'est assez obtenu avec une rigueur
extrême
bon ça dépend si les caractères ça m'a
peut-être amputé certaine forme de
sensibilité délicatesse mais ça m'a moi
ça va je suis très heureux de vivre avec
ce que je suis quelques poils qui te
pousse la magie j'espère qu'il connaît
bien
tout est de la faute des soixante
huitards sûr pas tout parce que là tout
près la mode la mode c'est que les gens
ne sont pas démissionner a les pères ne
sont pas dissimulent des missionnaires
on les a démissionné c'est la mode
social
oui les gens s'il arrive que les vous
dites que les mecs que les femmes
adorent c'est ceux qui doutent ceux qui
sont faibles
glissons buteur on est passé du père
attend déjà dur à jouer je schématise et
parce qu'il faut faire court on élargit
magie c'est la fin d'émission le huawei
ma mère idéale pendant les années
suivantes et je paie radial c'est vrai
alain souchon ouais c'est elle qui fixe
des wesh c'est un oui la vérité
ouais ouais on va y réfléchir ensemble
je marchais avec toi oui c'est pour ça
que vous dites les parties fortement
hiérarchisée ont de l'avenir
voilà le problème c'est qu'on est passé
du père idéal à alain souchon au père
idéal à la brousse quiz des corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus